endlich wieder auf den Markt gehen ohne
corona-test ohne grünen gesundheitscode
das ist erst seit einem knappen Monat
wieder möglich hier in Peking seitdem
die Regierung alle kobit-maßnahmen
aufgehoben hat auch die Shoppingcenter
werden wieder voll und der zugefrorene
die anmar Fluss egal mit welchen Kuchen
ab aufs Eis
vor zwei drei Wochen war es hier noch
komplett leer in Peking jetzt trauen
sich die Leute langsam wieder unter
Menschen zu gehen und man spürt richtig
die Freude endlich wieder draußen zu
seinem Sport zu machen und das Leben ein
bisschen zu genießen und dazu genügen
einfachste Mittel ihm reichen ein alter
Stuhl ein paar Schrauben und damit
zimmerte er seine Enkeltochter und ihrer
Freundin einen Eisschlitten
ich habe einfach ein Stück Teppich
draufgelegt damit die Kinder bequemer
sitzen können
Angst krank zu werden hat er nicht mehr
seine Kuh wird Infektion verlief harmlos
sagte
mit guter Laune wird alles gut
es sind die neuen alten Freiheiten die
hier viele genießen zum Beispiel wieder
Reisepläne schmieden
ich will überall hinreisen erst in China
und dann auch ins Ausland das werden wir
auf jeden Fall machen
doch gleichzeitig rollt in diesen Tagen
durch China die größte corona-welle die
das Land bislang erlebt hat als wir an
einer der fieber-kliniken drehen
schieben Angehörige einen erkrankten
einfach selbst über die Straße zur
Notaufnahme
hier im Hintergrund ist der Eingang
eines der großen Krankenhäuser in Peking
pausenlos kommen Ambulanzen Krankenwagen
hier an viele Menschen leiden an sehr
hohen Fieber an Lungenentzündungen die
Krankenhäuser sind voll wir konnten dort
nicht offen drehen sondern verdeckt mit
dem Handy aber wir haben gesehen dass
viele vor allem ältere Menschen hier in
einem sehr kritischen Zustand ankommen
sie werden auf den Gängen behandelt
viele haben Lungenentzündungen wir haben
es an den Röntgenbildern gesehen das ist
die andere Seite der schnellen Öffnungen
das Gesundheitssystem die Menschen waren
darauf nicht vorbereitet
in China gibt es nämlich keine
Hausarztpraxen wer Symptome hat geht
direkt zur Klinik das verschärft die
Situation zusätzlich immer mehr Ärzte
berichten in den sozialen Medien von
völliger Erschöpfung die Videos lassen
sich nicht zu 100% überprüfen doch es
werden immer mehr
ich habe gestern bis fast 1 Uhr nachts
durchgearbeitet keinen Schluck Wasser
getrunken und konnte zwischendurch nicht
mal aufs Klo
von den Auswirkungen der Pandemie ist in
der Öffentlichkeit nur noch ein kleiner
Teil sichtbar auch hier in Peking das
gilt auch für die Gastronomie
die was und Restaurants hier haben seit
den Öffnungen tatsächlich mehrere Wellen
erlebt rund um Weihnachten waren sie
richtig voll zum Teil aber jetzt ist
hier nicht so viel los das liegt auch
daran dass in den staatlichen Medien oft
verkündet wird ja wenn ihr kurbelt habt
bleibt lieber drei Wochen zu Hause ein
Barbesitzer hat mir neulich erzählt ja
für ihn ist es in diesen drei Jahren
Kurve mit die deprimierendste Phase weil
eben eigentlich alles erlaubt ist alles
auf hat und die Leute trotzdem
vorsichtig bleiben
gibt es schon so etwas wie Nachtleben in
Peking wer könnte diese Frage wohl
besser beantworten als eine Gruppe
Studierender
ich bin damals wirklich unter so
erschwerten Umständen hier nach China
eingereist habe vier PCR-Tests gebraucht
habe insgesamt 15 Tage Quarantäne hinter
mir und wirklich jetzt hier zu stehen in
der Innenstadt und einfach zu sehen dass
Menschen rausgehen das war's gefüllt
sind das ist wirklich schön
es hat sich sehr verändert am Anfang gab
es viele Einschränkungen wir hatten 10
Tage Quarantäne in der Universität
durften wir Monate lang nicht den Campus
verlassen und als wir ihn dann verlassen
konnten war alles zu aber in den letzten
Wochen fühlt es sich so an als ob sich
alles wieder normalisiert
seit September gibt es überhaupt erst
wieder Visa für ausländische Studierende
und jetzt haben Felicia Podolski und
ihre Kommilitonen in kürzester Zeit
alles miterlebt von Lockdown bis Partys
in Clubs man muss sich vorstellen in den
Köpfen der Leute ist ja die ganze Zeit
Kurve des gefährlich die Leute haben
Angst die Leute wollen noch nicht
rausgehen und wir haben eben meine
Freunde und ich sind alle aus Europa wir
haben ja eine ganz andere Einstellung zu
dem Thema und wollten dann
schnellstmöglich raus es ist eine
vorsichtiges Herantasten nach drei
Jahren Pandemie Peking zwischen
corona-welle und neuer Freiheit